-Congratulations on
your Academy Award nomination.
Very exciting.
-Thank you.
It's such a blessing, man.
I mean, ooh!
-Yeah.
-My mother said, like,
"Can you believe it?
A little black boy
from the South Side of Chicago
is nominated for an Oscar?"
I said, "Man.
That is an amazing journey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's great. And it's not
happening on its own.
You were also nominated
for a Grammy.
So you were there last Sunday?
How was that?
Did you -- Are you nervous on
a day where you're nominated?
-Well, yeah.
You know, it's, like,
unfortunately and fortunately,
they announced our award
pre-telecast,
so we already knew we lost.
We lost, so -- so I kind of got
to enjoy the event.
Like, I mean, I saw this
incredible performance
by Kendrick Lamar.
-It's amazing.
-You know, it was beautiful.
Even watching Bruno Mars
and Cardi B was fun.
And just seeing
Jay-Z and the guys
that I really love and care
about as artists and as people,
like Naz and Jay-Z around,
just enjoying the Grammys.
It was fun.
But I -- It was another one of
those moments,
because I pulled up --
when I pulled up to
Madison Square Garden
I was thinking, like, "I used to
watch the Grammys.
I used to see Michael Jackson
and never think that I could
attend that event."
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it's incredible.
-Well, it's incred-- I mean,
just the fact that
you're having all of these
happening one after the other.
It's like, "I'm at the Grammys.
I'm at the Oscars."
It's really exciting.
You know, you talked about
the people from your era,
the guys you came up with,
Jay-Z and Naz.
I always love hearing when
people help out
younger, unknown artists.
And you --
This was a photo you posted
of you and Chance the Rapper
when he was in "SNL."
He looks a lot older there
than he does in real life.
He's actually younger than you.
-Yeah, just a little bit. Yeah.
-But you -- Is it true that
your grandmother and Chance's
grandmother are friends?
-Yeah, yeah. Well, yeah.
They are -- they were friends --
I'll say that because Chance's
grandmother has passed,
God bless her soul.
But, so, my grandmother
and Chance's grandmother
were friends, and my grandmother
said, "Hey, Rashid,
I need you to call
and leave a message.
My friend's grandson,
he's a rapper."
And this is -- this is like
10 years ago.
So Chance had to be,
like, in high school.
So I ended up calling him.
You got to do what
your grandmother says.
-Yeah, of course.
So I -- you know,
and my grandmother
is known for calling me, saying,
"Say hi to this person.
Do this."
So I had to do it. I called --
-It's very nice that you still
answer when she calls.
That's very nice.
[ Laughter ]
-I better.
So, yeah.
I called Chance's phone.
I didn't know he was
Chance the Rapper.
At that point I don't even know
if his name was
Chance the Rapper.
But I left a message for him.
He didn't answer the call.
So I left a message,
an inspirational message
telling him to pursue his dream
and do it.
And then I met him
eight years later.
He said, you know,
"Our grandmothers are friends
and you left a message
on my phone.
I'll never forget that."
I said, "What?"
-Wow.
-"That was you?"
That was incredible.
And this dude went on
to win Grammys
and be one of the biggest
rappers out there.
-Well, good for you, man.
That is such a nice thing --
such a nice way
to pay it forward like that.
It's great.
-Would you do that for
an up and coming comedian?
-No, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
I can't stress how busy I am.
Just -- I just don't
have the time.
And then, you know, I'm on
a very limited minutes plan.
[ Laughter ]
So I want to talk about
"The Chi."
This is a fantastic show that
was created by Lena Waithe,
who's an Emmy Award-winning
writer on "Master of None."
And how did this show
come to be?
How did it come about?
-Well, she created it
because she said,
she saw a lot of reports
about Chicago
and the statistics that was
happening with the murder rates.
And she realized that
people weren't looking at us
as human beings.
The life that was being talked
about was not looked at as like,
oh, these are
human beings dying.
And this is not only the side of
what Chicago is, is violence.
So it sparked a thought
in her mind.
She's a creative person,
beautiful writer.
And she wrote the pilot for
"The Chi."
And as producers,
Freedom Road and my company,
we heard about the script.
It had a real big buzz.
And we came on as producers.
And it was like -- It was just
the right alignment for me,
me being from Chicago.
Me always wanting to tell that
story about human life
and just life being round,
not just one-sided.
And that's what
she was able to show.
-It's wonderful. You're --
obviously, we saw from the clip.
You're in it as well.
When you decide to be in
a project like this,
do you go at it
with a very specific,
"I want to play a character
like this"?
Or "I want to bring
this experience,
either my own personal
or people I knew
from that part of the country"
that maybe other people don't
know that much about?
-Well, yeah.
You know, they said, you know,
do you want to do
a character on it?
And I was like, "Yeah,
if the character is right."
And they wrote this character
named Rafik,
who was a Muslim brother
who was from the streets
and then, you know, went to
prison and has changed his life.
And I really definitely know
human beings
who have been
through that transition.
In fact, I've been working with
something called Imagine Justice
where we go into prisons
and talk to individuals
and see what programs --
And I've met some of
the most enlightened
human beings in prison.
So, to be able to play this
character and just be a voice
for people who are
usually unheard
was really an honor for me.
You know, I'm super grateful to
be a part of it as a producer.
But also to be
a voice for the people
who, across all America,
who don't usually get heard.